[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello good evening good morning and
welcome and I've swapped sides no sorry
mate
no no no no no I can't I can't be on
that side I can't
I'll start again hello good evening good
morning wherever you are in the world
and welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
and movie channel
we are here this evening with young Matt
to have a bit of a chat about am I
pointing the right way now Matt
I'm gonna Check Yes
um we're gonna do a bit of a star gated
chat we're going to talk about this SGC
series because I want to know what you
guys think but mainly we're going to
talk about some of the updates that
we've had in the last couple of weeks I
want to live if anybody wants to get in
the comments and you tell me what you
think live and we'll we'll answer any
questions you've got as well but also
just to have a chat with Matt and see
what he thinks about some of the some of
the um
update super five recently
the biggest one being the video I did
last week suggesting that a source I've
been speaking to that works in Hollywood
has said that Amazon have picked their
showrunner but we don't know who it is
it's it is Matt but anyway before we get
into that how are you Matt how are you
doing thank you for joining us I'm very
well how are you Jay
you know
I'm all good night
um as I said my wife's gonna she's not
coming back for four days so I'm taking
advantages to doing loads and loads of
live videos
oh God love it right so
let's just get into the show running
then because I asked people on the video
who do you think this show owner is and
we'll give a little bit of background on
in this so the guy I talked to who told
us about
um Mark Ferguson hall ghost B which
we'll talk about in a minute
told me that he didn't couldn't
understand why there wasn't that there
isn't a showroom so you do the
showrunner first it's the captain the
ship it's the boss it's the guy that
everything else flows through it's you
you have the show on it executive
producers producers and then you start
doing other things then you start
thinking about the show
he says this is hearing this stuff about
um potentially people that were coming
on maybe as producers and doing this
work was backwards
but then he said the rumor that they
have picked a showrunner
um that it's not dotted and contract
signed yet because this person has a
contract with another
um streaming service or another
um Studio they cannot formally agree
until that um contract is resolved in
the video I talked about I said when
that contract ends but actually that's
not what he told me and he did correct
me I did get a message saying that's not
what I said [ __ ] and I was like oh
yeah
um he actually said that the contracts
resolved
um so he says that so that it may be
that they're trying to get this person
out of a contract
and that they think that I'll be
resolved around Christmas time this
person wants to leave their contract but
they're having to go through all that
rigmarole
um or whatever it is for whatever reason
it needs to be resolved
so
um
that's where we're at
first of all what did you think about
that news when the video dropped did I
actually tell you before the video
dropped that that had happened or I'll
just dropped the video I can't remember
nope you just dropped the video and I
watched it
with everybody else I did it really
quickly as soon as I got that news I was
like boom boom I've got to get this
video go take this video out quick so I
didn't I didn't mess around
yeah as soon as you as soon as the video
dropped
I I always look through the comments as
I'm watching a video and I saw loads of
people mentioning Amanda Tapping
um and was quite excited about that and
I thought watching it you were going to
say oh Amanda's tapping is definitely
going to be doing it but I wish that's
not the case we don't have a definite we
don't know exactly who it is yet
I then thought well if it's not Amanda
Tapping
who could it be and thought well the
only there's loads of people who it
could possibly be but the one person I
thought that was very
uh I don't know who the one person who
loves Stargate the one person who wanted
to bring Stargate back and wanted to
actually buy the franchise
was Joe Flanagan yeah and I thought that
would be a good pick but the only issue
I have with it is
has he got experience behind the camera
he might he may have we were talking
about this before we may have written an
episode or two first Target Atlantis but
did he ever direct did he ever do has he
ever done anything
big like a big project I don't remember
him I'm sure he wrote and I think he
directed a couple of episodes of
Stargate Atlantis but I went on his IMDb
and it's he's got no
no credits for it for anything like that
but maybe I was just looking at it wrong
but I couldn't find anything
um he has got sorry I went through
excuse me I went through a couple of
people that have been
listed because I'm using I'm following
this thing of they're contracted to
something right so that's my hint
so one of the names that came up
um was Robert Cooper Robert C Cooper who
was obviously one of the initial
creators who's who co-created with Brad
Wright he's not signed up to anything at
the moment according to IMDb unless he's
contracted to something else that he's
not being credited for on IMDb it could
be something else so I think we could
scratch Robert C Cooper off because I
don't see any reason why it couldn't he
couldn't jump straight into that
um Joseph malozi
um is signed up and he is writing he's
just created a TV show called Utopia
Falls he was the creator I think that's
ended
um but he is signed up to write
something called powder Mage which is a
project at the moment so
um so yeah that that's a possibility
um Joe Flanagan signed up
um by something called room 19 which
he's going to be acting
Amanda ping is signed up to produce a TV
show called synthesis season zero and
she will be producing and she's
potentially going to appear in a horror
movie that's the only thing is as well
so out of all of those
with the amount of tapping thing that
that synthesis
the wording of that season zero
is a bit strange is that just like oh
it's called that is it yeah it's
actually called synthesis colon season
zero oh okay because I was thinking is
that just a pilot that they're going to
be doing or something if it's season
zero a pilot and then a season one well
my thinking on that one is if it was
Amanda Tapping and that was the rumor I
heard a long time ago that Amazon would
love Amanda Tapping to come and do this
she's a well-known director she's she
has executive produced a couple of shows
including Sanctuary which she was
basically she was virtually the
showrunner for Sanctuary she did
everything
um and she used executive producer on
this um that Salem thing that she just
finished doing
um showrunner would be the next logical
step for me
um she has directed she has done
everything else
um
um
so
it's a possibility for me you're the man
to tapping and it would make sense to me
that there's this contract issue she
signed up to this
um synthesis zero
but then this possibility about Stargate
and potentially running a major
franchise has come up and they're
negotiating together at the contract
I'm wondering if that's a possibility
that's me just completely spitballing
but they're negotiating to buy her out
of it or to get her out that whatever
that is
um or
she's only signed on to maybe do a pilot
and as soon as that's done she'd be free
to jump ship
again
just maybe you know
um I think I think those are all
possibilities
um
yeah
sorry
loads are you doing at the moment
malozi uh
he's just down to write something called
powder mage
the CV series that he made Utopia Falls
I think is done so uh
possibility it could be him
Joseph malozi is a possibility
um personally I hope not but that's I've
got very Personal Agenda against Joseph
from losing afraid I'll be straight up
with that I just don't like the guy
a particular actor from the Stargate
franchise
um to see if he had any experience and
he does have producer experience hmm
um
so whether or not the next step for him
would be maybe showrunner and one of the
things you said in your video is that
Stargate fans would be happy with it
it's Richard Dean Anderson himself
he's an old man though
and would he want that response it'd be
a lot of work I mean the one of the
reasons why he stepped back away from
Stargate was that he wanted to be
involved less I wanted more time for a
charity and family and stuff
yeah he wanted to spend more time with
his daughter who who'd been now in her
20s oh yeah she's interested I don't
know but I mean yeah I mean the fans
would go crazy if he wanted to do it
it wouldn't it wouldn't necessarily have
to be
forever he could do the first season he
could bring Stargate back
yeah
and the fact that would go crazy as you
said and do you remember I meant he was
he was a co-owner of gecko that brought
the show back first time around it was a
Anderson whatever company that produced
the first was it four or five seasons
under gecko
um
so he is a businessman he knows how
these things work
um it's possible I'd like to say if you
want to if you're Amazon
and you want to silence critics
immediately all the people going you
know reboot and don't ruin Usher if you
want to silence all those people really
quickly have Richard Dean Anderson
involved in any way yeah
um everyone would just shut up and just
wait for the show to be made
you know talking all about this though
since we we worry about that you know
talking about Joe Flanagan that he
hasn't maybe got the experience the
thing is Amazon have got a little bit of
form when it comes to just giving these
big massive jobs to just the most random
freaking people so I mean you look at
rings of power you know the writers have
virtually no experience and they were
given you know given this um I don't
think that the the the the main guy The
Producers hasn't got a great deal of
experience either
um in big projects like this and they
let them run with it so maybe it's just
a matter of they've pitched it to so
many people
and I suppose it's the case of
he may not have the experience on paper
but he has been entrenched in Stargate
for years he still goes to conventions
he's he he lives and breathes up
obviously he does other things but he
loves Stargate yeah
exactly having someone like that
is going to be surely better than just
getting Ben from down the road
so to pick it up and then have them
watch the entire franchise try and pick
it up try and learn the Canon whereas he
already knows because he was in it yeah
David Hewlett which is another name that
would
if he doesn't come back
you see I'd want him to be on screen as
well again he's got no producer or
anything like that experience as far as
I know he's got no experience at all or
anything never showing the desire
um Joe Flanagan has shown the desire to
do this the way I understand the process
um how Amazon does it is that basically
they will right so again the guy I
talked to he says a lot of these rumors
have happened because Amazon have been
approaching different people
about
would they be interested in being
involved in something along these lines
if they brought Target back so that's
why a lot of these rumors spread because
Executives at Amazon are approaching
people
he's actually said that's why he's
interested at the moment that's why I
think something we're getting closer to
getting something officially announced
is because the rumors seem to have
stopped yeah and this most recent thing
about the the showroom has been
approaching they know who they've picked
the person but apparently how it works
is like a job interview they invite
people and they come and Pitch their
ideas and they sort of that's and that's
how they did it with Lord of the Rings
the writers for the Lord of the Rings
the rings of power got it because they
pitched the best idea
um and the Amazon Executives went yeah
that's the job you're in they didn't
really look at their experience they
just they just pitched the best idea
um
so
if they approached Joe Flanagan who they
know has had this thing and they said if
we were to do Stargate what would you do
and he just pitched some
they loved
it's not necessarily a problem that he
hasn't got they can bring other people
in to help him with the managerial and
you know and a lot of the production
side I think executive producers and
things like support him now if he's
gonna just run the show and run this you
know Steer the ship in our Direction
yeah
um who are going to have the experience
in actually making or writing good
television he can literally just sit
there and be like this is where I
Envision it's gonna go make a story for
me
and that's what it means if he's gone
into the executive producers or whoever
at Amazon and gone this is what I
envisioned for the show that for the
franchise because let's be honest they
want to do a franchise they're not
talking about one seriously they're
talking about
Star Trek Style
franchise
and where they have
potentially three four series on the Go
at once eventually
um
if he's come in and gone this is what I
see over the next 10 years phase one
Stargate boom this is what we want this
is what I want to get us to in five
years time and they blew them maybe
maybe so but I think the same for Amanda
Tapping I think Amanda Tapping if
they've gone through her agent and gone
we are thinking about bringing Stargate
back would you want to be involved if we
did
I'd love to okay well what would you
envisage for it would have to be the
same thing and maybe Amanda Tappan came
in and just blew my ore somebody that
we've not even bloody thought of because
Amazon used to doing that Peter DeLuise
is one that I think would come back in a
heartbeat
and again he's not really doing anything
at the moment he's got he's directing
something called Christmas angel
for which I imagine is a straight to
there's not much information on it on
IMDb but it's going to be straight to
wherever Christmas movie isn't it TV
movie
this whole thing about Christmas keeps
coming up
um you know Christmas time that we'll
get a firm answer maybe it's because
he's doing that at the moment and as
soon as that's done he can sign on to
start again
Peter DeLuise he obviously he did do a
lot of directing and stuff for Stargate
anyway
that would
actually be produced yeah I I do one I'd
heard your bets on that
I I wouldn't give you great odds on it
like 250 57 episodes he did for sg1
yeah he was massively involved and his
whole family was massively involved you
know it was just like oh yeah his dad
was an ergo wasn't he yeah his dad was a
go
um his wife was involved he met his wife
on the show his both of his brothers
were involved at different points
um
his
I think he I think even Dom deluise's
wife was involved in one episode or
something like that but the list of De
Louise family that were involved in the
show at different times was really long
it's like
um he is an established director
he's not really doing anything he knows
the law he knows the cannon it's
definitely a possibility and again I
think it would have been his fans he's
not
you know he's maybe not the name like
he's not he hasn't got the name of a
man's tapping
yeah another name I want to throw out
there though
and that would again appease fans
immediately and has got some directing
and writing credits to his name
um is Michael shanks
yeah I like that I'll let that mole
was he done
the last thing I saw him in was
um he's on some medical show at the
moment
I find that I watched I can't remember
what it was called though
oh what's he doing so director he's
directed Saving Hope yeah and he's done
sg1
yeah that's the Saving Hope I think is
the medical drama reason at the moment
isn't it I don't watch it
but in my follow him on Twitter so he
keeps Twitter
um
but it's all about that thing though
about
appeasing fans and I again what I get
told by the by the couple of people that
still work at MGM that I talk to is that
um one of the things that has been
discussed is that the fans and and all
the stuff on social media and everything
um
they've got a very loyal very
um motivated fan base that they've got
to really be careful about and and I
keep mentioning like sort of Star Trek
the people are passionate about it in
the same sort of way that people are the
trekkies are and they said and the same
sort of
they don't want to have the new Trek
problem where actually they bring back a
new show
and the original trackies the Star Trek
fans
are some love it but equally some people
hate it and I'm really angry and it's
it's harmed the franchise and they don't
want to do that again
you know so they have to respect Captain
they have to respect what's come before
it and not
change anything that happened before to
do new things but everything that
happened happened yeah well let's say
the one guy I speak to said he's he's it
is a big part of his opinion it is
largely his opinion but he does work in
this area he said basically that he
thinks they will do sort of like a trek
style thing where it's like a hybrid
they say well Canon will still be
they'll basically go through and pick
what the important points of Canon are
and they'll reference them but then and
that's part of what Mark Fergus and haw
Coast be doing at the moment is they're
producing this sort of like um series
Bible for the new series and it'll focus
on what they're not what they're allowed
to mess around with and what they're not
allowed to mess around with and there'll
be certain story points that are that
are like concreted in Canon and they're
not allowed to mess around with but
anything else is fair game and if they
have a story that is interesting and
they think pushes things in the right
direction they will be allowed to play
with Canon a little bit
I don't know I feel I'm I'm a bit
when it comes to Canon I'm a bit um
I'm a little bit more relaxed than some
people but I'm more stressed than others
I do think there are certain things you
can't
[ __ ] about with
and there are certain things you can and
Star Trek has always messed around your
Canon and like like say like I'm a I'm a
Trekkie Star Trek has always messed
around a Canon
but there are certain things they don't
they don't mess with and the problem is
new track is they those lines of blurred
and there's there are things that they
shouldn't mess around with that they do
they were always really good at it
before but they've got the thing
Stargate can't make that same mistake
hmm
I agree there's there's certain things
I wouldn't really care if they changed
but there are
fundamental things you can't change
like if they all of a sudden change the
gate like now it's open for like it
could it can be open indefinitely Or
I don't know I'm just trying to think of
anything but I
I just don't want them to do what
sometimes what they'll do with Star Trek
though is that they um so we're just
going to get rid of a idiot in the
messages
um I want to do with Star Trek is
they'll they'll come with really lazy
reasons why they've they've broke
Stargate or broke Canon
um and that annoys me
um you know and you know oh they do time
travel something and explain it or I
mean there's lots of things that could
like say the gate opening forever they
could say well there's and you know an
app update or something you know
um
and or a new technological technology
update or something that that they would
have had so they would have to
understand
how the gates work to a point even
beyond the ancients for that to happen
though I don't think that would work
yeah
um they could do something like you know
how the gate opens just because and
there's no Event Horizon and stuff I
mean they could just say that they
figured out how to do that and because
we've seen that in canons that wouldn't
be a problem
um there are things they can do and to
to to change it up again what I wouldn't
like to see is I would like to see like
a completely different sort of gate
um Brad Wright was saying about how he
wants to like they're gonna that we've
built our own
um and I can kind of see a point to that
maybe but
I can see Targets on the ships maybe
might be interesting but the only
the sort of thing with the man-made
Stargate
it's if it's not broke don't fix it yeah
like what's wrong with having the Milky
Way get if it was
if they had their own mermaid gate I
would prefer it if it was more of a oh
we figured out how to do short distances
so we can get from Earth to
the moon base on Atlantis Atlantis moon
base
we don't have to use beaming technology
I mean beaming technology is going to be
infinitely better than for that purpose
but I mean you know short distance is
not like halfway across to the Galaxy if
it was just short distances
I think that would work
advancement to the ring technology or
something yeah Improvement to that yeah
I can see that there's lots of ways they
could do it but I I understand as well
Star Trek and I'm going to keep going
back to this example of Star Trek
because I think it is the show
it's definitely the franchise we want
Stargate to
um at least on like a numbers or a
thingy point of view that should be our
competition that should be what we
should compare it to
um how popular it is and whatever I'll
say that
Stargate for me should be his biggest
Star Trek because it's just I think it's
better so but anyway
um Star Trek will change things for the
sake of it in new track you know they
change the Klingons why
they did it because they wanted to
freshen it up a bit and they thought you
know I don't know I actually think
sometimes the Star Trek they do things
to annoy
um fans because then they'll talk about
it and if they talk about it it's
getting social it's getting attention
and you know it's it almost feels like
that's what they're doing
but
but what they do with Star Trek is
they'll throw in an odd little Easter
egg or something that they know fans
will pick up on
um and then they're almost like it's
almost like oh look over here look over
here don't worry about all this stuff
that we're changing we're messing around
with because we mentioned that character
that only you know about that only you
remember them but you know what I mean
it's like
I I don't want them to do that with a
new series I don't want them to do this
if they do this hybrid
idea where they they change certain
things to allow them to do a new show
and to you know
um
I think there are things they're gonna
have to mess around with just to make a
new show make sense Maybe
um and I'm okay with that
um but it's got to be done in a way
that's a lot cleverer than they did with
Star Trek
like
for changing how the ships work
what I mean is
Towery ships are very humanly built
they don't look futuristic
I mean they do because they're
spaceships but they they look like
something we would build yeah yeah it
looks like something the US military
would just slap together and say this is
a spaceship I'll go is it doesn't look
like one okay
I wouldn't want it to be like
I don't know
about this now because I like the
futuristic element of Stargate
but I like I also like it being grounded
in reality
I wouldn't want the ships to be Star
Trek ships
super futuristic with super futuristic
technology I'd like it to have some sort
of
grounding I guess to to now like still
have futuristic technology like the
Wormhole drive for example that's fine
because we've already seen that in the
in Canon anyway so that's that's fine to
me that makes sense that they would
develop next Evolution isn't it yeah
yeah
but if
they created a series and it was a
ship-based series like you mentioned and
the ship was like it looked more like an
Asgard ship or it looked more like
just something from Star Trek it
wouldn't feel like Stargate
yeah
which we've talked about that loads
times now and then we want Stargate not
Star Trek 100 yeah the technology has
gone so far that that's a concern
um
but yeah
what do you think about Mark Ferguson
Hawk host be them if this if this rumor
is true and it is arumu it's not been
confirmed so we have to take it with a
little bit of the pinch assault but if
they really are sort of like I think
they really have been asked to produce
this
and Bible is the only way I can turn it
but if they've basically been asked to
put something together they're like okay
if we do a franchise what would it look
like which is basically what they did
for the expanse they were given the
books and they were going right make
this into a series
all they've been done now is they've
been given the three series before and
gone right
how do we make this into a new series so
it's a similar thing that they're doing
what do you think about that generally
as a if it's true I'm quite excited for
the possibility of them being involved
having as I've not seen all of the
expanse but I mean I'm
I've just finished season two I'm on
season three now
I've seen enough of it to know that it's
that I really like it but I like the
style of it I like that
although it's set in the future
the ships feel very slapped together
not the
um not the rosie but
you know some of the other ships they
just feel very slapped together and they
feel like something that would I don't
know they feel
I feel grounded they feel realistic yes
the difference if you're on the Belt
like you would just make do with what
you've got you'd slap something on the
wall to patch a hole
it feels yeah as you say grounded they
bought that real realism or grounding to
new Stargate
I'm I'm all for it and that's that that
excites me
I was hoping you're saying that to
Grandma's because I'm saying there are
similarities between
um not the storyline or whatever but
there are similarities between the way
the expanse was made and the way
Stargate was made talking about it being
grounded in a reality in that there's no
very fancy warp drives or something like
this that even though
technologically is is possible it's like
you know we don't you know the
engineering of it might be out of our
league but um I know I still have
hyperspace windows don't mean Starkey
but there's no there's no signs of how
they work but but there's there's always
that reality or that grounding into
something that we can recognize is like
that's
that's possible that's that this is
actually I mean I always think when I
watch the expanse I always think this is
the closest thing to Psy reality rather
than SCI fiction in that it's I could
see this is what and you're saying like
the belt is and the and the way they
would live
when you've got
um humans on us reality when we've got
lots of resources and lots of money then
we make things that are pretty
you know we build nice churches we build
a nice architecture you know we we build
planted cars and things when we are just
doing it for the sake you know I think
we build ugly big ass factories and
stuff but it just works it just does
what it's supposed to do you know
um and they can be horrendously ugly but
they work and they they can get they can
get rusty and they can you know thing
but as long as they're still working
they just fix them we patch them up with
it look at an oil rig for example
they're not pretty are they
um and I think that's what I was like
going on the belt is and I think that's
what people do when we when we have the
time we like things to look nice and we
would do that in our you know in our
ships and our bases in the future but
when we don't we don't we just make them
functional
yeah and they did that in the expanse
you know the Mars ships because they
were the power of the solar system they
were their ships were prettier you know
and their bases were nice certain things
and you could see that in the designs
yeah the belts that's why I've mentioned
that the rosie wouldn't I wasn't
categorizing that in that because it was
a Mars ship so
but yeah um
drawing a blank of what I was about to
say so someone just walked in and walked
out
yeah how dare they were alive
your family
um I've got an empty house it's a
glorious so um no I think I'm sorry
what I was gonna say
oh God it's gone again sorry
I was excited when I heard this thing
about Mark Ferguson hawco's being not
just because I think Hawk ospi is the
greatest name ever and I really want to
be called Hawk
um if I if I could change my name
tomorrow I'd change my name to Hawk max
power uh I might even investigate how
much it costs do that come on why max
power because this sounds awesome
um I have Hawk power Hawk max power come
on
um but um
you know it's just like when I heard
these guys were involved I was just
thinking that's perfect they're coming
off the show
if they were if they were going to be
executive producers executive producers
even write some episodes because you
know remember they wrote a lot of the
episodes for the expanse as well
that's a Duo that bring a lot of
experience and then you're talking about
um a showrunner he would you know if it
wasn't Amanda Tapping who's never done
it before if it was
um
um if it was
um
uh even Joe Flanagan say they would lean
on
Mark and hawk a lot
yeah and they if if more if Mark and
Hawke do more than just this Bible and
actually do come on as producers which
is what they did for the expanse so why
not as far as I know they've not signed
up for anything else Mage at the moment
no well no actually
um I think it's Mark Fergus in
particular has actually got lots of
projects on the go but they're mostly
writing gigs
um then I think that could be really
amazing and and these guys as well they
tend to work together really well but
they even when they were doing the
expanse they used to both wander off and
do different projects because they
really do work as a team so one would
sort of focus on the expanse while the
other ones got off doing something else
and they would you know constantly come
back and work together and then they'd
you know almost like share the
responsibility a little bit so they can
do that again so it doesn't concern me
that if you look at their IMDb they've
got a lot of upcoming projects because
it's they did during the expanse as well
and they kept on top of that so
um
but but yeah I just think whoever does
come into showroom will lean on these
two guys a lot and it doesn't worry me
so much because I I when I said when I
first put this room out nine months ago
that Amanda Tapping was being tapped up
one
um that you know if somebody comes well
she's never done that before so she
can't no it's rubbish and I'm like
she's doing everything but yeah
you know she's she's active it would be
the next logical step
and the best show Runners aren't
necessarily writers and stuff anymore
they're managers
you know they're
Kevin Fey has never written or directed
anything as far as I know he was a
producer and then he stepped up to show
one and he's the most successful
showrunner or you know Captain the ship
in probably modern history with what is
your Revival
yeah
they
yeah I don't know I don't know why I
can't get my words out tonight I must be
knackered or I've got words in the
morning
um
what I was gonna say about Mark Ferguson
and
um what's his name
come on how can you forget Hawk
I was gonna say Mark
Mike Fergie and Hawker yeah
what I would be excited for
um if forget who the show runner is so
if it's Amanda Tapping if it's Joe
Flanagan whatever then as you said they
were going to lean on Mark and Hawk to
to to to create something great
what I was going to mention about the
expanse and something that I really
liked this is going back to being
grounded in reality and something that I
loved about Stargate
was
the thing I liked about Stargate was I
could picture it being real with the
expanse
things I've noticed just how the ships
ships move things like that really
grounds it for me there was one
particular thing that I
um I thought was really cool and it was
in it was over in season two or season
three
um essentially the pilot I can't think
of his name of the Rosie
had to go through the
um you know when they they done like the
martial law in the in the system
um he had to go through
the the gaps but he did that using
Gravity from all of this celestial
bodies yeah
he was completely silent he had no
thrust he literally just used gravity to
get around and that is the kind of stuff
that I'm like well yeah you would do
that
have we seen that they take
um a you know I'm thinking about like
the black hole episodes
and things like that when they take
known physical things but they use it in
a slightly way that makes you go oh that
[ __ ] that clever yeah something you
know just like um that for me that was
one of the that's again one of the
Hallmarks of Stargate and I know that
come from the writer because I'm pretty
sure that was in the book as well I did
read the books but it was a long time
ago sorry
um that was in the book so it's come
from the writer but you know
that's that's to me again it's one of
those connections between the expanse
when they bring back Stargate all over I
want you to feel and look more like the
expanse than I do than it looks like new
Trek
if Stargate comes back and you think
this feels like Trek I'm going to
possibly hurt somebody and I'm not
saying that now I know I'm on I'm on TV
at the moment kind of so don't take that
as a legal threat I don't want to get
sued but I I will I will lose my [ __ ]
I'm gonna drive down to your house and
just punch you in the head on TV it's
not your fault either but um I'll just
just commit violence against somebody
I don't know
it's really funny if I just like
disappear asking that appeared
do that one day
um
but but you know what I mean it's just
like
they can't
one of my biggest fears is that they're
gonna [ __ ] this up and you know what I
looked at the
um
Star Trek Picard trailer today we I
talked about in the live stream just
I've done a video very quickly on sytrix
sides and please go and check and check
that out
um but I did say the adverts look
amazing Picard series one looks amazing
they let me down Picard Series 2 looked
amazing first episode was brilliant they
let us down
card Series 3 looks amazing how are they
gonna let us down because they're gonna
Stargate genuinely when the first series
airs
I will do a video and it will be me
there going [ __ ]
because I'm going to be [ __ ] it
because I'm I'm you know I'm invested in
this show like no other
how are they going to [ __ ] it up is my
fear yeah and guys get into the comments
you really don't want them to yeah
not ruined but you know they're not as
good as they once was Doctor Who for
example
yeah I'm very annoyed with Doctor Who at
the moment I still love it
Doctor Who is still one of my favorite
TV shows I'm still going to watch Power
of the doctor when it comes out in two
weeks I'm very excited for it
but this latest like last like three
four years has just been
boring
um
just boring let's don't want Stargate to
ever be boring let's talk about the
elephants in the room then
and you know I don't like the word woke
I don't like it
um but for lots of reasons I did a video
about a couple weeks ago that made
people very angry so I won't go into it
again but it's the word that describes
what we're going to talk about
lots of TV shows at the moment seem to
have they're very concerned about the
agenda they're very concerned about
hitting as many demographics as possible
they're very
I think we've got an entire culture
that's very worried about insulting you
know upsetting anybody we mustn't upset
anyone and I'm like
you know
we've all got human rights kind of
but no one's got a right not to be
offended that just doesn't happen you
know everyone you know if you're going
to get offended by something that's
that's on you not anybody else
um unless I physically come into your
house and punch you stuff I say on the
screen really shouldn't be a problem if
I say something and you don't like it
tell me that I don't like it and then
that's that should be the end of it
really unless I say something like and
to incite violence or something which is
a bit different but you know I shouldn't
want you I was going to mention that
unless it's
an actual hate speech or you're rallying
people up to get angry at a certain
individual or a demographic to cause
violence or upset on purpose
the only thing that should be illegal is
if I if I say stuff that incites
somebody else to commit a violent act or
to commit hatred I should really be able
to come up here and go I hate this and I
hate that and I hate something else even
if it is really offensive I should
really be able to do that and a society
has free speech
and then don't get me wrong you would
all come and rightfully come and tell me
why I'm an absolute
see you next Tuesday
but
um
the one thing I shouldn't be able to do
is is say something that incites
somebody else to commit violent act and
if I do say if I say something I hate
this and then somebody that watches me
that is you know as a fan of this
channel goes out and commits a crime
based on what I said I'm comparable
yeah you know I'm just as guilty as that
person as far as I'm concerned but I
should be able to say pretty much
whatever I want
um I don't want to say things that are
hatred because I think what you put out
into the world is what you get back you
know I generally believe in karma in
these things so I try to be positive but
I also try to be honest
yeah um well people whenever I say
to anyone
that I've not enjoyed the last three
four years of Doctor Who I'm gonna use
doctor as an example because it's a
great example
a lot of people will take that as oh
it's because it's a woman doctor isn't
it yeah that's true she's been great
I
watched her in uh shows before and when
she got announced I was super excited
because she's worked alongside David
Tennant
um you know she she knows the role like
she's she's good at it the reason
that I don't like the last three four
years is because the writing has been
terrible I mean Doctor Who is [ __ ] holy
as well Peter Capaldi I stopped watching
and Peter cabali took over I I watched a
first few episodes and I stopped
watching it there were a few episodes of
Capaldi's which were really good yeah
but not not many yeah I I would agree
with that but yeah I'm counting the
Capote Capote in that as well because
well Whittaker has only been doctor for
two years three two three three if at I
can't I can't remember how no I think
actually it was 2017. she got announced
I really can't remember but anyway the
point I'm trying to make is
if you say you don't like a TV show a
lot of people will take that
as
fuel I guess just to be like oh it's
because of this demographic oh it's
because of
this person's black or this person's gay
or it's a woman and it's
unless you say that that's not what you
mean don't like I I wouldn't want
someone to think
I have that Viewpoint just because if I
say I don't like the current season of
Doctor Who for example and someone in
the comments says says that then that's
my viewpoint like it's not
my only issue is maybe that and people
do get very angry about
black characters gay characters and all
this sort of thing and like I say I
think sometimes people use the term woke
to actually just Express their own
bigotry
when I do know they've got a point when
it comes to certain things like in
characters and Star Trek when it's a gay
character say but
they really go on about it quite a lot
and you're just thinking well they
wouldn't be going on about it this much
if they were heterosexual but for me I
don't care if
um I've got I've got friends I know it's
one of those things that all racists say
I've got friends that are black and but
no I got friends that are gay I do not
give a flying that he's gay it doesn't
bother me in the slightest
um I'm not a Christian I don't think
he's committed any sins
um and and it doesn't bother me and the
funny thing about it is the actor isn't
actually gay he played a gay character
yeah certain thing I remember years ago
um
I I remember Eve's um I was I was a girl
at the time and we thought of two guys
kissing and I apparently went oh and and
it sort of held their hand out and I
just went away and she was like and she
was like oh [ __ ] I'm dating somebody
that's like homophobic and she's then a
couple weeks later we saw just two
people a girl and a boy kissing and I
went oh and she's actually like grabbing
she goes because because for God's sake
I thought you were homophobic and stuff
you just hate public affection don't you
I was like yeah I shouldn't she's doing
her at home
I don't care who's doing it I just don't
wanna I'm British
so many people
um you know but um
and I'm not on the same but it just
seemed at the moment
Hollywood I think somebody just said
this
um what was the thing
don't care no uh Kevin here's a bummer
melosi told me on Friday you can't
produce anything holiday without being
woke
um
I do not agree with Joseph malozi's
politics I'm going to straight up there
I've talked to Joseph Mosey a lot and I
will I will be honest with you I've
blocked him
um because
um on Twitter because he made me quite
angry don't talk to your Heroes is my
advice
um his views on the environment made me
angry
um
so I just don't like I said I tried to
put that out there everyone because if I
say anything negative about Joseph and
Rosie I don't want it to
you know I want to be honest about why
is writing and everything else is always
brilliant and I love and if he came back
in Stargate I would support him and but
if ever he tried to put his politics
into a show I would be the first one to
go [ __ ] because you enjoy his
product you don't enjoy him it's
separating art from the artist yeah
exactly same thing with like JK Rowling
she's
a terrible person but I love Harry
Potter yeah so we can go we can separate
the two that's fair
um
but most story writers and things they
do they do put themselves into the story
so there's things that they're
passionate about do as good all the best
sci-fi has got layers to it has got an
agenda to it they're trying to tell you
something you know or teach you
something or highlight a problem in
society or whatever else
you know um there's a lot of Android
storylines that are really commentaries
on slavery and
um or attacks on our freedom and things
like this that's the that's where the
Android or the robot story sort of like
starred in Last sci-fi
um
you know it's layers to it and I have no
problem with that
I do have a problem
I was gonna say it's about Hollywood
seems to be
if Hollywood has been racist for a very
very long time
um it's it's very clear that in lots of
movies the top actors the black actors
regarding how good they are Denzel
Washington Morgan free and whatever else
they get paid a lot less than the
equivalent
you know stars that are white it's been
massively sexist for decades and still
to this day women actresses earn half
what the male does you know and and they
can't say anything Chris Pine earned
more than um Gal Gadot in both of the
Wonder Woman films even though the film
is freaking called Wonder Woman he's the
leading lady
the most and she got paid less
you know
um there was a statistics I don't know
if it's true or not but apparently the
guy that used to be in 90210 appeared in
Sharknado like six or something and
apparently got paid more than Gal Gadot
did for the first Wonder Woman movie and
I don't know if that's true but if it is
true that's just it's one of those
things I I believe
you know
um and it's just wrong but it does feel
like a lot of Hollywood now feel so
guilty about it but to be honest they
probably should
um but they feel so good they almost
like go in the other way they're almost
like making it like it's almost like
every thing they do now is like has to
be like an apology letter and I was like
you know what
it's not
okay do it a little bit but then let it
go
and it is a different take different
take
I've just thought about it because
obviously you mentioned storylines and
things
and
um like issues being raised in sci-fi
like tilk and the whole Jafar is like a
commentary on slavery and is led by a
very prominent black
male actor yeah
um
the way it's going now though
is it not just that we're steering away
from from casting let's I'm just going
to use black
um actors and actresses as an example
here
we're not casting them as slaves
in the storyline to be to to to
highlight what slavery was now we're
just making them more
just regular characters
what's wrong with that that's that that
should be how it's always it should have
always been because I feel like it would
have been back in the day when you hired
a black person it would be because oh we
need
we need to be authentic and we need to
have
like slavery was for black people so we
need a black person to do it yeah
and that's the characters that they they
typically behind the casting as well
yeah yeah whereas now we can just hire
a black person a gay person a trans
person just to be a person a character
not without any
backstory kind of thing just just
they're just there
yeah it shouldn't matter I'm saying half
of the cast of any major TV series
should be female because half the
population is female in theory depending
on what what it's set in obviously I
mean exactly if you do a TV drama in a
hospital really there should be more
women than men
um 20 to 30 percent in anywhere in the
west should be sort of ethnic minority
because that's the that's the thing and
a good proportion should be some sort of
homosexual but the point is that can be
part of their character it shouldn't be
it shouldn't overtake the storyline the
story
should be the thing it's a lot of these
things the Sci-Fi is a metaphor for
slavery for something else in
Australians but it's layered my problem
is sometimes
it's just it's just smacks at it in
Picard series two episode two there's a
scene with seven of nine and the other
woman whose name I can never remember
and they're just sort of like talking
about the story and they say blah blah
blah blah and then there's just this
weird scene that sticks out because they
start talking about the race riots
um and it's got nothing to do with
anything it's got nothing to do with the
story at all and then they just go back
to the story and it's just it's just
like what was that
and it was it's an agenda bit but
um just being
here and being gay shouldn't be a plot
point
unless unless the story is like a drama
about
gay people
the best one that I've seen that do that
though was it was the the home of the
gay Point did the comma point the plot
point was when they made sulu's
character in the last Star Trek movie
gay
um
he just passed away
and obviously he was gay and he was a
big fighter of gay rights so
um so they made sula's character gay
there was nothing in actual Canon to say
that he wasn't he had a daughter but
they just said well they adopted or
whatever
um and I thought that was brilliant but
that did that did stick out but it was
with a point and it was it was brilliant
it was it was so nice and actually truce
again true Star Trek fans well they're
going yeah that's brilliant real nod to
the actor and I love that but that's
thing but anyway quickly to talk about
this because we've only got a couple of
minutes and we we promised we'd be done
by nine didn't we I haven't had my tea
yet so
um how possible is that Target series
Tim so let's just round that up
um if you are new to the channel
um
then you know
fair enough but if you're a regular star
Trekker you'll know that it's it's very
possible if I was to give it a
percentage
I would say it's any TV show in Pre in
early planning stages can go wrong and
can be scrapped
and until it is actually green lit
and they've signed on to pay for at
least a series it's 50 50. about whether
it can happen or not
um I can tell you
for a fact
that
um there is some pre-planning going on
after that it's rumor
I can tell you for a fact Amazon are
looking to bring back Stargate and
that's 100 I I'm handing my heart on my
children's lives I know that for a fact
all these other things are
you know you gotta say good to pinch
yourself because there's lots of
information out there like I said I get
told loads of things about Stargate I
don't share because I either don't
believe it
um or I for whatever reason no it's not
true because I get I get loads of
information if I do get piece of
information that I think is a rumor but
it's interesting I will tell you but I
will tell you very carefully that it's
it's a rumor
um but I would I would say that it's I'm
90 certain Mark Ferguson hawkosby are
doing this Bible it's possible it's not
true but I'm like 80 90 certain it's
true
and I'm 80 90 certain that the new
showrun has been that they've agreed a
new shown
whether that leads to a show
I'm 50 50. I'm absolutely certain though
actually I'm 100 certain Stargate will
return at some point
I'm certain it will it's too big a
franchise not to
um
but I I see it a bit like Star Trek how
it everyone got a bit Trek fatigue and I
think people did get Stargate fatigue
people got a bit bored of the show
it needs like 10 or 15 years off like
Star Trek had and then come back with
something that's a bit new
yeah and I'm hoping that's not going to
be a hard route but I don't think a a
hard reboot can't happen because not
enough time has gone by
Battlestar Galactica work because 30
years had gone by
um and that was okay
um I don't think that could work but
um and I think Star Trek Target fans
would go crazy but um I'm 100 certain it
will come back at some point whether
that's
I'm I'm I would say that I'm 50 50 50 50
that it's not being announced at
Christmas I'm 50 50.
whether something to be I'm 100 within
the next five years or I've started
100
yeah certainly our universe didn't help
the the end of Stargate I guess but I've
said it before it would if it if they
didn't do Stargate Universe then and
they've brought it out now it would do
way better
yeah
yeah I think so I think Stargate
Universe was possibly slightly ahead of
its time but the other problem with
Target Universe it was so different to
sg1 and SG Atlantis I think it turned a
lot of Stargate fans off
Stargate fans even now are very much
split down the middle about SGU they
love it or they hate it well it almost
put me off
I saw the trailer and it was it wasn't
Stargate how I knew it or how or how it
had been ever
but I gave it a chance and I and I loved
it a lot of a lot of other fans probably
watched the first season but then then
gave up on it and I don't blame it for
that because the first season was
very slow yeah
the second season
fantastic and if they'd have had a third
it would have it would have gone on for
years I reckon but
yeah and it's a shame really they didn't
have a bit more trust in it to be honest
because it was getting better and how
many Cypher we keep saying this how many
Sci-Fi series over the years have had
not very good first second series
the first season of The Next Generation
wasn't very good they had to mix it up
they had to you know Jordy they kicked
George's of Forge into engineering that
killed natashi yarov they read they'll
rejig the show and it was went on to be
you know the you know the start of a
massive franchise
um the first series of Stargate wasn't
very good stagger sg1 they had no money
there are some brilliant episodes but
you look back at it now like oh it's a
bit dated
yeah when I go through my rotation of
watching it again the first season is a
bit of a slog like I don't enjoy it as
much as the late seasons
yeah
but SGU
um you see in the comments now going
there was no humor in SGU
um George didn't think Eli was funny
it wasn't funny Eli was supposed to be
the comedy in that series but the
problem was
it didn't work he wasn't particularly
funny and
um the the genius of Stargate was it was
it was like it was funny in places it
was situational comedy in places it was
it was slapstick in places but it was it
was always sort of like I said this in
another video it's always really
grounded humor it wasn't humor for
humor's sake
people in difficult strenuous stressful
situations particularly I mean I'm
British would were terrible at it we we
make a joke when things are bad
um you know and that's what Stargate did
I watch dramas all the time and they
think oh God it's so gritty and true to
life and I'm like it's not because
there's no humor in that situation
somebody would crack an inappropriate
joke
because it's what we do it's how we
can't I do disagree with you about Eli
not being funny though he was he was
like he was my favorite character as
well he's my favorite character by mile
as well Ross him and rush rush was the
polar opposite that he was very serious
and very angry he was just an angry
Scotsman I just yeah loved his character
but Eli I thought was he was the most
grounded I think he's likable he wasn't
funny he wasn't laughing funny he tried
to be but it wasn't it didn't work but
he was the most likable by a mile
right anyway look guys in the comments
tell us if you want us to come back and
do another video like this because we
were going to talk about our SGC series
and we forgot
um because we started talking about
other things then please let us know if
you want to come back we can we can do
this every few weeks if you want us to
so please let us know and we will anyway
because we like talking about it so
thank you Matt for appearing I'm very
very hungry I'm going to go now
um and I've done three hours of
recording this afternoon
sorry thanks Matt
say goodbye
bye please more videos please more
videos like this yeah okay okay we'll
we'll do it then good night guys have
fun bye